Hello folks, I'd like to start with a song
and the lyrics of the song are:
"Walk light, ladies,
the cake's all dough.
You need not mind the weather
if the wind don't blow."
So if you can repeat after me,
"Walk light ladies, the cake's all dough."
Audience: "Walk light, ladies,
the cake's all dough."
CGJ: "You needn't mind the weather
if the wind don't blow."
Audience: "You needn't mind the weather
CGJ: Ok, so you got it. So I’ll sing.
(Singing) “Walk light, ladies,
the cake’s all dough,
you needn’t mind the weather
if the wind don’t blow.
Walk light, ladies, the cake’s all dough,
you needn’t mind the weather
if the wind don’t blow. ...
Walk light, ladies, the cake's all dough,
you needn’t mind the weather
if the wind don’t blow.”
Hardly anyone knows that song anymore,
but it was a popular one
during the slavery era.
Black Americans sang it on holidays
and during a dance contest
called a cakewalk.
But what you may not know
is that drag queens probably sang it
at some of the earliest queer balls
in the United States.
And you also may not know
that drag culture shares a history
with African-American emancipation.
The reason you don't know
is that Black queer communities
have largely been erased from history.
That's in part due to the fact
that so much historical research
begins with genealogy.
And what is genealogy?
It's basically a record
of heterosexual behavior:
mother, father, child;
birth, marriage, inheritance.
But another reason
is that historians of all colors
have looked down
on Black queer folks like me
as immoral, deviant,
distasteful, diseased,
even dangerous.
And the long-term impact of that
is that many of us don't learn
how Black queer people
have shaped history.
People like Bayard Rustin,
a gay Black man who organized
the March on Washington in 1963,
leading to the passage
of the Civil Rights Act.
Or Frances Thompson,
a formerly enslaved Black woman,
assigned male at birth,
whose harrowing congressional testimony
about the Memphis race riots of 1866
helped shape the course of Reconstruction
and galvanized support
for the 14th Amendment,
which provided Black Americans
with citizenship rights
and the promise of equal protection.
As an effeminate Black kid
growing up in Louisiana,
I was bullied a lot.
In elementary school,
the other kids called me a girl
and I felt out of place
almost all the time.
If I had learned in school
about the contributions
of Black queer people,
it would have made
an enormous impact on my life.
I think recovering these histories
can save kids' lives.
But after spending the last 15 years
researching and writing
about these topics,
I would like to make the case
that learning Black queer history
is crucial to understanding
our shared history.
So you've probably heard
that the fight for queer liberation began
with the Stonewall uprising.
New York police raided
a queer bar in 1969.
Riots followed and magically,
a celebration of pride was born.
The problem is, that's not true.
(Laughs)
Queer pride did not arise out of nowhere.
There had to be a foundation
of self-acceptance
and solidarity in place already.
And in fact,
many people had been working for decades
to build the courageous
and confident community
that made Stonewall, pride
and eventually,
marriage equality possible.
One of those people
was William Dorsey Swann,
the first drag queen.
Swann was born into slavery in Maryland
just before the Civil War.
In the 1880s, as a young adult,
he moved to Washington, DC
to find work to help support
his parents and siblings.
In Washington, he found
the Emancipation Day parade,
an enormous annual celebration
commemorating the end of slavery
in the US capitol.
The highlights of the parade
were called queens:
Beautiful, crowned Black women
who personified African-Americans'
newfound freedom.
The queens of Emancipation Day
so inspired Swann,
that he adopted
the title "queen" for himself
at the secret dance
that he and his friends called "a drag."
The word "drag" possibly comes
from a contraction of "grand rag,"
which is an early term
for a masquerade ball.
So although people assigned male at birth
have dressed in feminine clothing
for all sorts of reasons
throughout the centuries,
the term "drag queen" began with Swann,
who was the earliest documented person
to call himself a queen
of a cross-dressing party
described by its participants as a drag.
The title queen signified
that Swann held an honored place
in the community.
But the term "queen"
is even more important
because it's one
of the earliest positive terms
that queer people had
to describe ourselves.
In the 1880s,
positive terms like "transgender"
and "non-binary" didn't exist yet.
"Homosexual" was a word
only used by Germans.
And although "gay," "lesbian"
and "bisexual" were English words,
they didn't mean what they mean today
and they weren't used to self-identify.
So it can be tempting to apply modern
identities to people of a distant past.
But if we do so,
we often fail to consider and respect
the ways that they thought of themselves.
Right?
If we fail to consider how our ancestors
thought of themselves,
we risk erasing a crucial element
of our shared history.
Swann's balls were raided
numerous times by the DC police
leading to jail time
and eventually a public petition
and a bid for a presidential pardon.
That makes Swann the earliest
documented American activist
to take legal steps
to defend the queer community.
But the authorities couldn't stop Swann
and couldn't stop
the balls from continuing
and expanding to other cities.
Today, queer drag is mainstream.
From “Paris is Burning”
to “Pose” to “RuPaul’s Drag Race”
and the houses of 21st century
ballroom culture,
which feature queens who preside
over beauty and dance contests,
have maintained the same basic structure
as Swann's 19th-century community.
The history of DC's Emancipation Day
has largely been forgotten,
but the power to choose
how we define ourselves, as Swann did,
is more important now than ever.
And as long as the term "queen" lives on,
anyone who participates in
or enjoys watching drag competitions
is paying homage to
a century-and-a-half long celebration
of African-American emancipation.
And William Dorsey Swann
is just one example.
How many other Black queer stories
have been erased
from the historical record?
And what could those stories
teach us about who we are?
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)